[Musique]
c'est en mettant les pieds dans ce
restaurant de montréal qu'on découvre
cet étonnant mais péruvien
voici des cas au saas préparé par daniel
silva rey ex le chef connaît bien ce
plat très populaire au pérou enfant sa
mère lui en préparer régulièrement je
fais une grosse couche des patates du
dos rond quand maillot avocat et notre
grosse couche des patates main d oeuvre
un peu de maillots c'est comme le pâté
chinois près mais voilà en face à vesoul
à casela puis le met le mieux ça tue la
finisse jamais
l'histoire de ce plat remonte à la
guerre d'indépendance du pérou il y a
deux cents ans alors que des femmes
voulaient aider leurs soldats leurs
armes la pomme de terre
qu'est ce qu'on fait on va la
transformer en purée c'est injuste peut
pas donner des patates bouillies aux
soldats on va racheter un petit peu de
sel un petit peu derrière mieux que
dimanche on prévient qu'ils ont
transformé la patate en petites galettes
en purée un petit peu piquant petit peu
salée puis il vendait sa dans les rues
et et criaient pour la cause pour la
cause qui est elle une position du pérou
puis c'est ça la cause la case ça c'est
de là que le nom de se stationner venir
car la base de tout calza c'est cette
purée de pommes de terre à la texture
élastique comment tu arrives à faire une
pâte comme ça c'est vraiment le fait de
rajouter le liquide sur l'huile de
canola si ça vient beaucoup aidé avec
qui ne soit pas celle qu'elle assèche
pas beaucoup c'est vraiment le fait de
retravailler la la purée comme ça la
place exactement c'est comme la place
tient compte du plaid au jeu
[Musique]
le chef nous propose aujourd'hui trois
versions on va commencer avec la plus
populaire c'est notre cas c'est cool
pour le livre de la pieuvre aux olives
mans produit alors 5 600 étage et on a
de l'avocat la base tu peux en cube
notre fameuse purée de pommes de terre
cas où ça notre meilleure base des
olives noires préviennent les boutiques
ça ressemble un peu aux livres kalamata
un petit peu avec pierre grillet sur le
dessus et on finissait avec jimmy tuerie
pour un petit côté arbas et el hakim
afrique
[Musique]
voilà
dans un propos
toujours à base de pommes de terre et
d'avocats il ajoute à la seconde 15 des
crevettes pour celle ci le secret est
dans la sauce excellent là c'est quoi ça
c'est la mayo quadrillé da au pérou on a
beaucoup d bouffe de rue ou dans des
chariots et les chariots peut aussi on
n'a qu'à pétillent alors c'est un peu
comme des reines maillot des rues un peu
sa base darif en cadets rôti d'agneau
rôti de coriandre c'est quoi la première
est gardien pendant qu'à la réponse à
ces impies monotype depuis ma part il
est un peu ma cantine beaucoup pour de
marivan dopé au son des piments assez
chaud à cheval pour juger que les
banques aillent et pas très relevée
c'est plus un côté fumé un petit côté
chipotle je te dirai qui ont fini ça
avec duquel grillet sur les dessus rate
un petit croustillant de cette couleur
ce bond girl pour son troisième place
daniel prépare d'abord le letchi des
tigres et lecce des petits c'est la
marinade un ceviche aussi simple que ça
daniel prépa sont légers des tigres et
le les deux tigres avec un poisson blanc
comme le mahi mahi importé de son pérou
natal auxquels ils ajoutent celles jus
de lime céleri et des branches de
coriandre si on met le feu là les tigres
et devient verte documents qui vont
mettre de la marche est plus côté
gingembre et notre côté relevé ça c'est
typiquement limon simplement privées et
voilà on va laisser tremper sans un
petit 30 secondes et on passe au blender
on ajoute ensuite de l'oignon et de la
classe c'est un élément l'iiasa des
remous side
regardez cette belle mousse ça
daniel cuisine maintenant la caixa a
sévi tchad a inspiré d'une autre
spécialité péruvienne le ceviche un
ceviche c'est du poisson blanc marine et
vend des jus de lime celle korian
d'oignons rouges là n'en rajoutons pas
des puits mamba qui aiment à lyon
dimanche ont péri 20 ont fait que ça
donne une couleur jaune quand même très
flash alors à la base on à l'avocat la
patate notre budget on verse les petites
chaussures le dessus la table financier
privé du les tigres et on finit avec la
patate douce frites sur les déçus
comment on peut la décrire la cuisine
péruvienne je te dirais c'est une
cuisine très humble très heureuse on à
l'océan on a la jungle on a les
montagnes de la les patates les poissons
tout plein d'éléments qui ensemble se
sont très bien rassembler les pages ça
on a aussi des grosses influences comme
l'implant chinoise influence japonaise
des cuisines très connu dans le monde
très riches qui sont venus en plus c'est
rajouter à tous que nous un autre bagage
déjà que dernière c'est super beau
disposer de la bouffe de rue sur la base
c'est la boule de riz pluvial mais si ça
représentait un peu plus un film un peu
plus gastronomiquement et les gouttes
ont la version civile chez label calza
assez vite
chassée
d'avocats la patate
la taille autrement
que de fumer
avoir le goût la source d'olives noires
athlètes ce côté
du missouri une belle façon de
réinventer la bouffe de rue
une grosse coche au dessus tout original
ses bons souvenirs